continuamos con más información del
acontecer internacional aquí en france24
y es tiempo de los temas económicos
estamos con daniel hablando nuestra
periodista que nos va a contar lo más
importante de daniela y hablamos de un
fin de semana electoral en la región de
américa latina por un lado perú y
producto ecuador colecciones
presidenciales además de olivia
conexiones regionales empecemos con
ecuador y el panorama económico para el
próximo mandatario daniel a los
ecuatorianos el domingo van a elegir
entre el banquero conservador guillermo
lazo y el economista de izquierda andrés
araus en la segunda vuelta presidencial
el país que deja lenin moreno está
marcado en términos económicos por una
pandemia que empeoró todos los índices
el producto interno bruto veamos del
país cayó 75 por ciento en 2020 después
de haberse mantenido casi estable el año
anterior tiene una tasa de desempleo del
5,3 por ciento cuando antes de la
pandemia era del 38 y tiene una deuda
pública de 63 mil millones de dólares
que representa el 62,9 por ciento del
pib en términos sociales
tasa de pobreza pasó del 25 por ciento
antes de la crisis al 32 4% el año
pasado estas personas viven con un
ingreso menor a 2,8 dólares al día
entretanto en liliana el 14,9 por ciento
vive en la pobreza extrema o sea con
menos de 1,6 dólares por día además uno
de cada tres trabajadores recibe un
salario mejor al básico que equivale a
unos 400 dólares también hay que decir
que los inversionistas están observando
muy de cerca a este resultado porque
araus ha prometido renegociar los
términos de un acuerdo financiero con el
fondo monetario internacional
en cambio el lazo mantiene una visión
muy favorable hacia el libre mercado y
hablamos ahora de perú también daniela
con un panorama electoral bastante
reñido pero como viene panorama
económico pues la desigualdad y la alta
informalidad son los mayores desafíos
económicos que tendrá quien llegue a la
presidencia de perú se estima que el 70
por ciento de los empleados peruanos
trabaja sin contrato y más de una
tercera parte del comercio no paga
impuesto a las ventas es decir es
informal
fue uno de los países de la región con
mayor impacto económico de la pandemia
cayó un 11% y el desempleo saltó al 14,5
por ciento esto es más del doble de lo
que era accionar su deuda de 69 mil
millones de dólares equivale al 35 por
ciento del pib es relativamente baja en
comparación con sus países vecinos en lo
que a pobreza se refiere el más reciente
dato disponible- tiene corte a 2019 en
ese momento uno de cada cinco ciudadanos
vivía con al menos 3,2 dólares por día
además el 2,9 por ciento vivía en
pobreza extrema con 17 dólares al día
para ese entonces se estimaba que casi
un millón de personas no podía adquirir
la canasta mínima de alimentos todos
estos indicadores seguramente son muchos
más altos ahora después de la pandemia
la dieta y cambiamos de información
porque presidente de eeuu presentó al
congreso su propuesta inicial de
presupuesto para 2022 si liliana pues
esta propuesta por 1,5 billones de
dólares enviada al congreso incluye un
aumento drástico en el gasto
climático y en escuelas públicas pero
generó preocupación bipartidista sobre
el gasto militar este es un adelanto de
una solicitud completa de presupuesto
anual que la casa blanca dará a conocer
en los próximos días se estima que el
recorte de gastos del pentágono que
desde unos 769 mil millones de dólares
irán a cubrir un aumento del 41% en el
presupuesto de educación también otro
aumento del 28 por ciento en comercio y
uno del 23% en salud habrá también una
partida adicional para la lucha contra
la crisis climática por este mejor gasto
en defensa a liliana el presidente fue
blanco de críticas por parte de los
congresistas republicanos cinco de ellos
liderados por el líder de la minoría en
el senado mitch mcconnell emitieron una
declaración en la que lo acusan de no
querer confrontar a países como china
angeli cuéntanos cómo están para hoy los
indicadores económicos pues se registró
un doble récord en wall street' de
amazon subió un 2,2 por ciento en la
bolsa después del intento fallido de la
creación un sindicato de eeuu
europa la bolsa de londres cayó a la
espera de que el reino unido siga
levantando restricciones y en américa
latina la bolsa de sao paulo cerró en
rojo
bueno la cifra del día anhela 7.000
euros liliana a partir de este sábado
del gobierno de españa' ofrece un bono
por este valor a sus ciudadanos para la
compra de vehículos eléctricos como una
manera de promover el cambio a energías
limpias veces por la información de
colombia en el aire ustedes gracias por
estar en las 24 continúen con más
información nos vemos más adelante
[Música]
e